ليلى وعبد الصمد لا ينقطع الامل لا
بالنسبه للاهالي بايجاد احبائهم ولا
بالنسبه لفرق الانقاذ هنا في اديمان نحن
في موقع جديد هذا المبنى سمحت لنا فرق
الانقاذ بالتواجد فيه لفتره قليله للاطلاع
عن كثب على عمليات الانقاذ والانتشال هذا
الموقع حددت فرق الانقاذ وجود ثلاثه اشخاص
سيده وشابان لم يقول تقول فرق الانقاذ ان
كان على قيد الحياه ام لا يقولان انهم
يعملون على الوصول اليهم لتبيان وضعهم
والعمل على سحبهم الدمار كبير في اديمان
هيئه افات قدرت بان عدد القتل حتى الان
فاقه 3,400 ضحيه عدد المباني المدمره تزيد
على 2600 مبنى في مدينه واحده فقط
بالامس كما ذكرتم تم انتشار سيده على قيد
الحياه بعد اكثر
ساعه نحن دخلنا اليوم السادس وفرق الانقاذ
كما ترون تعمل بشكل خفيف على محاوله سحب
من يتواجدون في اماكن في الاماكن المنهاره
الوضع جدا دقيق نقول دوما ان الوضع دقيق
كما ترون الى جانب هذا المبنى هناك مبدا
شبه بنهار ولم يسقط بشكل كامل تحاول
الاسراء فرق لانقاذ الاسراع بالعمل على
هذا الموقع خشيه من انهيار هذا المبنى او
تحطم بعض اجزائه ما سيصعب عمل هذه الفرق
هناك اليات ثقيله تتواجد في الموقع لا
تعمل حتى الان تعطي المجال لفرق الالقاد
في محاوله للوصول الى الاشخاص الثلاثه
الذين هم على قيد الحياه قبل هذه الرساله
المباشره التقيت باحد الاشخاص هنا كان من
ساكني هذا المبنى فقدت 14 شخصا من عائلته
في دقائق كما قال لنا وهناك المزيد من
افراد عائلته تحت الانقاذ فرق
الاسعاف تحاول تهدئه العائلات تحاول
التهدئه من روعهم وتطميمهم بانهم يعملون
ما في وسعهم على انتشار الضحايا
قبل هذه الرساله جلنا في مناطق في احياء
في مدينه اديمان حقيقه الوضع لا يمكن ان
يوصف بكلمات ان قلنا فهو كارثي الوضع اقسى
من ذلك هناك احياء بكاملها عشرات المباني
في كل حي سكني
انهارت بشكل كلي بشكل كامل لم يعد لها
وجود باته انقاض حطام المباني التي لم
تنهار متضرره بشكل كبير جدا على الاقل
هناك اربعه احياء في المدينه تمكنا من
مشاهدتها مدمره بشكل كامل لا يستطيع احد
العمل في تلك المواقع لا يستطيع احد
الوصول الى تلك المواقع الكهرباء فيها غير
متوفره وفرق الانقاذ
بالاحرى بلديه المدينه والجيش يمنعون احد
من الدخول اليها لان جميع المباني التي لا
لم تنهار معرضه للسقوط في اي لحظه باتت
منطقه محظوره على الجميع
بعض المناطق الاخرى كهذا المكان الفرق
تعمل فيه امس تمكنت السلطات المحليه من
استعاده العمل ببعض الخدمات خاصه الكهرباء
والمياه يقول افاد افادت ايضا بانه تقريبا
75% من الخدمات الاساسيه استعيدت في هذه
المدينه لكن
اديمان تحتاج الى جهد كبير على المستوى
الاغاثي هناك
محاولات لبدء اقامه اماكن لايواء السكان
تم اجلاء اعداد كبيره من السكان اجلاء
الجرحى من يمان لا يتم فقط برا امس وصباح
هذا اليوم رصدنا تحليق طائرات هليكوبتر
طبيه يبدو انها نقلت مجموعه من الجرحى او
المصابين يعني المنتشرين من تحت الانقاض
الى
مستشفيات في اماكن اخرى لم نستطع تبيان
العدد الذي تم نقله جوا ولكن شاهدنا عمليه
النقل على الاقل
طائرتيها هليكوبتر نقلت هذه الاصابات خارج
ادمين بالنسبه طبعا هذا بالنسبه للجرحى
الذين ينقلون عبر طائرات الهليكوبتر
لتلقي العلاج ولكن بالنسبه للسكان الذين
تضررت بيوتهم بيوتهم ونجاوا ويتم اجلائهم
هل هناك ضوابط لعمليه الاجلاء بمعنى هل
سيتم اجاؤهم فقط الى اماكن امنه في داخل
المحافظه نفسها ام الى محافظات اخرى
عبد الصمد المرحله الاولى من عمليه
الاجلاء تركزت بشكل كبير على نقل السكان
من المناطق المتضرره بشكل كبير ونقلهم الى
اماكن امنه داخل المدينه هذه هي المرحله
الاولى المرحله الثانيه يتم فيها التنسيق
كيف سيتم ايواء هؤلاء عند حدود المدينه
ليس داخل المدينه على الاقل حتى الان والى
الاماكن التي سينقلون منها من يرغب بترك
المدينه السلطات تقول انها ستساعدهم على
الانتقال رئيس الجمهوريه زار المكان اكد
ان جميع من فقد منزله سيتم تامين مكان
للسكن مؤقت الى حين اعاده اعمار المدينه
الامور تتم بشكل منظم الى حد كبير حتى ان
نحن نتحدث طبعا عن الاحياء وعن المنتشرين
من تحت الانقاض على قيد الحياه وعن من بقي
حيا من نجا من هذه الكارثه وهذه اولويه
بطبيعه الحال الاولويه للاحياء ولكن كما
شاهدت ايضا يتم تنظيم عمليه
التعرف على
الضحايا في كل موقع منهار تقوم فرق
البلديه بمساعده الطب الشرعي بتحضير اماكن
تنقل اليها اجساد الضحايا ويتم التواصل مع
العائلات
للتعرف في عمليه التعرف على
هويات الضحايا هذه مساله قانونيه مهمه جدا
تتولاها وزاره العدل التركيه كل ضحيه يتم
التعرف على عليها يتم تسجيلها من بين
الضحايا وايضا يتم ترتيب عمليه دفن
الضحايا بشكل لائق وبشكل لا يعني لا يضر
لا بكرامه الضحيه ولا بكرامه العائله
واحده من الامور التي سمعتها تكرارا خلال
تواجدي في اكثر من مدينه منقوبه من فرق
الانقاذ تحديدا احد قاده فرق الانقاذ قال
لي نحن نعمل حتى عندما نجد ضحيه قد الحياه
نعمل على سحب هذه الضحيه بشكل لائق نحرص
قدر الامكان على ان تكون الجثه مكتمله
يقولون نحن مسلمون وهذه ومن المهم بالنسبه
لنا حفظ كرامه الضحيه وتسليم الضحيه الى
عائلتهم الى عائلاتهم بشكل لائق وسرعه
دفنهم لامور صحيه وايضا كي يعني جزء من
عمليه مباراه الثرى للضحايا تمكن العائلات
من بدء تقبل مساله ان هؤلاء الاشخاص قد
فارقوا الحياه وتبدا مرحله التعافي
بالنسبه لهذه العائلات طبعا الطريق طويل
الصدمه كبيره ولكن هناك ايضا بعض السكان
من يتولون مساله الدعم النفسي ولو بطريقه
اجتماعيه يعني بمسانده هذه العائلات
وبتقديم الدعم لهذه العائلات
شكرا جزيلا لك السلام